[Music]
hello everyone
i'm ishihara from the pokemon company
today february 27th
is the date the pokemon red and pokemon
green games were released in japan
marking the beginning of the pokemon
series
we've now reached our 26th year since
the birth of pokemon
thanks to the support of all you
trainers around the world
thank you
each and every one of you
today
we would like to present the latest
updates on a number of games
so i hope you'll watch to the very end
mr utsunomiya please take it away
[Music]
hello i'm takata utsunomiya from the
pokemon company
allow me to jump straight into sharing
the latest updates with you all
first is an update on pokemon go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
pokemon that first appeared in the alola
region of the pokemon sun and pokemon
moon games will be appearing in the
world of pokemon go beginning march 1st
[Music]
until then alolan executor will be
appearing in pokemon go
we hope you'll try catching them for
yourself
[Music]
now
i'd like to share some news about a few
of our other games
[Music]
this february pokemon masters ex
celebrates its two and a half year
anniversary right now as far as trainers
go there are
over 142 in total that you can team up
with
powerful sync pairs from many regions
have assembled on victory road our
newest feature
completing victory road not only can you
team up with sigma suit red sigma suit
blue or sigma suit leaf
but you can also receive 5 000 gems
starting tomorrow may and latias arrive
with may in a special outfit this sink
pair can turn the field of play into
psychic terrain powering up all psychic
type sink pairs skyla and tornadoes also
debut with skyla in a special outfit
this sink pair can turn the field of
play into a flying zone they're skilled
at supporting flying types and using
interference against opponents
and there's more you'll also be seeing
ryhan and flygon with ryhan in a special
outfit with moves like sandstorm and max
flare they can create several weather
conditions to celebrate the two and a
half year anniversary of pokemon masters
ex players now have the chance to scout
up to 100 sink pairs at no cost but
that's not all if you log into the game
after this presentation ends you can
receive a present of 3 000 gems as our
latest campaign begins we have a variety
of other content lined up as well
now is the perfect time to play pokemon
masters ex don't miss out
[Music]
pokemon cafe remix the puzzle game where
you mix and match alongside pokemon
introducing deliveries a new way to play
heliper will deliver drinks and dishes
to pokemon far away and spread word of
your cafe
at pelipper's destinations you'll have
the chance to meet pokemon that are new
to pokemon cafe remix gather new special
outfits
and unlock hidden specialty gimmicks
that give you an edge and puzzle
the mythical pokemon victini appears for
the first time in pokemon cafe remix
during your deliveries its powerful
skill will be very helpful in the new
puzzle mode coming early 2022 deliver
drinks and dishes to victini to have it
join your staff additionally there will
be three events to celebrate pokemon day
the first event is bulbasaur's happy
pokemon day there will be a seven day
special login bonus and on your first
login you can get bulbasaur's limited
time celebratory crown outfit for the
second event there is an increased
chance of shiny piplup appearing
starting now for four days shiny piplup
will have a greatly increased chance of
showing up at your cafe use this
opportunity to have it join your staff
and for the third event you can use an
11 times express delivery item at no
cost we'll give you the chance to try
out the new delivery feature 11 times
you won't want to miss this
as the second anniversary of the game
approaches this june get ready to
welcome tons of new pokemon to the cafe
have fun playing pokemon cafe remix on
both nintendo switch systems and smart
devices
[Music]
since pokemon unite launched last july
lots of pokemon have joined the fray
together with unique pokemon like
dragonite
aegislash
or greedent
form a team in battle
fire off your pokemon's moves over and
over in new intense limited time battles
full fury battles added today february
27th
you can try out any pokemon in standard
battles and quick battles on special
days posted on the official pokemon
unite website
furthermore there is a pokemon day event
happening right now in pokemon unite
the mythical pokemon hoopa joins the
roster during this event
hoopa can warp ally pokemon to other
locations
use blindsiding team tactics to get the
drop on the opposing team
using hoopa's unite move turn into hoopa
unbound and go wild
while the pokemon day event is going on
all players can try out hoopa
clear all special missions and you can
obtain hoopa's unite license
all players that log in now will receive
commemorative pokemon day trainer
fashion items
use this pokemon day event as a chance
to experience the heated battles in
pokemon unite and finally enjoy a
preview of the next pokemon that is
slated to join pokemon unite in the
future
please continue to look forward to more
content in the future in pokemon unite
available on nintendo switch and mobile
devices
next allow me to share some news about
the pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
soon we'll send out oak's letter an item
that will allow you to encounter the
mythical pokemon shaman within pokemon
brilliant diamond and pokemon shining
pearl
you'll be able to claim this item as a
mystery gift later after this
presentation ends
you can add shaymin to your team and
enjoy exploring the sinnoh region
together
next up
we have some news about the pokemon
legends arceus game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we are pleased to announce the daybreak
update for pokemon legends arceus which
will be available to players at no cost
you'll begin a new investigation into a
curious phenomenon that is causing mass
outbreaks of pokemon across the hisui
region
you'll also be able to engage in new
pokemon battles together with your ally
pokemon at the training grounds
the daybreak update will be available
later after this presentation ends
and as a pokemon day gift we'd like to
offer you some items that should come in
handy on your adventure
please enter the provided password in
your game to claim this gift
we hope you continue to enjoy your
adventures in the his region
one more thing
we are pleased to announce that
production of an online animated series
set in the history region has begun
this series will feature an original
storyline and is anticipated to launch
later in 2022
please wait for future announcements to
learn more
[Music]
what did you think
we hope you all look forward to how
pokemon games will continue to evolve in
the future
we've shared with you today the latest
information about a variety of our games
but to wrap things up we'd like to end
this presentation by sharing one more
video
thank you for tuning in
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you